now that we have a database we can take
advantage of an Android pattern to bind
our view to our data model known as a
content provider a content provider
allows us to think of our view data in
terms of URIs which is a convenient
structure for our applications we can
have views display different data based
upon which URI is currently active as it
turns out a URI is the primary data
member for those intents that rato so
gloriously described with a combination
of content providers and intents one can
nicely decouple the data being displayed
from the view and there's one other
great thing we get from using URI with a
data location it's easy to have our
database notify components that are
registered to observe that location
which causes our cursor to update our
list and show the latest data content
providers can return all sorts of data
but typically they return either a list
of items or a single item here's how one
might modify our query to select the
data for a specific date rather than a
range of days which in this case also
contains more information for the viewer
to see